y
[Música]
a
el colectivo caminando fronteras
denuncia que más de 700 personas
migrantes han perdido la vida este año
intentando llegar a las islas canarias
en embarcaciones que salen su mayoría de
marruecos mauritania y senegal a estas
desapariciones en el atlántico se
conocen porque el colectivo caminando
fronteras monitorea las fronteras
europeas aquí en marruecos entre
comunidades migrantes sus familiares
servicios de rescate y defensoras de
derechos humanos intentan poner nombre a
las víctimas de las fronteras en este
caso se han contabilizado 700 en la ruta
canaria pero aseguran que podrían ser
muchas más las que no constan y es que
ante un incremento de la vigilancia en
el mediterráneo' las personas migrantes
han asumido rutas más peligrosas como es
el caso de la canaria ahora mismo el
flujo migratorio hacia las islas
españolas es cinco veces mayor al año
pasado y por otra parte la asociación
marroquí de derechos humanos insiste en
que hay un incremento de las detenciones
y de las deportaciones en la costa del
sáhara desde donde salen gran parte de
las embarcaciones y denuncian que las
inyecciones económicas de la unión
europea para que marruecos frene estas
salidas implican vulnerar el derecho a
la libre circulación de las personas
[Música]
una vez más la isla de lampedusa en el
extremo sur de italia ha sido el
escenario de repetidos desembarcos de
emigrantes en la última semana más de 25
embarcaciones han llegado a las costas
de esta isla con a bordo centenares de
emigrantes que abandonan el continente
africano atraviesan el mediterráneo
huyendo de la guerra o de la pobreza y
llegan a esta pequeña isla de tan solo
20 kilómetros cuadrados que no cuenta
con las infraestructuras necesarias para
recibir a tanta gente casi 700 migrantes
son actualmente acogidos en el único
centro de alojamiento previsto para
solicitantes de asilo el gobierno ha
tenido que enviar gigantescos barcos
para repartir a estas personas y que
puedan ahí respetar un periodo de
aislamiento sanitario cada migrante debe
someterse a un examen de coronavirus al
ser identificado
un noble éxodo que para muchos ya es
triple 130 mil migrantes volvieron a
venezuela con la llegada de la pandemia
lo hicieron procedentes desde colombia y
toda américa latina a pie por peligrosos
caminos recurriendo a la mendicidad y en
algunos casos incluso la prostitución
según human rightswatch los retornados
se encuentran en condiciones de
hacinamiento y falta de higiene en los
centros de cuarentena unas condiciones
que pueden propagar más el kobe 19 los
migrantes venezolanos huyeron de la
crisis política y económica que vive el
país al llegar a lugares como colombia
trataron de empezar una nueva vida
muchos con la llegada de la pandemia
perdieron sus precarios trabajos y
quedaron desatendidos en muchos casos en
improvisados campamentos repartidos por
toda la región siete meses después en
pandemia y en plena reapertura se espera
que más de cien mil venezolanos vuelvan
a cruzar la frontera en algunos casos
por tercera vez desde 2015 más de 4
millones de venezolanos han emigrado a
otros países de la región siendo
colombia con más de un millón y medio de
personas el país que más acoge a
[Música]